if they win tonight and they go on to
win the NBA title are they then in your
mind the best team that's ever played so
they're the best team at this particular
time in the history of the NBA but what
they have an opportunity to accomplish
what they've already done is remarkable
to the time Bulls record for the number
of lists and a chance to set the
all-time record I don't know if people
can appreciate this how amazing it is to
go through an entire NBA season play 82
games and only have single digits that
they won the game tonight as far as a
number of losses that's remarkable it
really truly is and there are a number
of games that maybe people say that they
should have lost they were lucky to win
well they had to do something good to
win but they also had no number of games
where they just easily have won and they
did so it's a great performance in a
great team a very exciting team to watch
it's rare that I in the years that I
would DVR a game and want to sit watch
it if one of my boys wasn't playing and
now I do that and I just look hard to
actually watching this team play because
there's so much fun to watch and they're
exciting and Steph Curry is as exciting
a player the watches has ever been in
his own way Michael Jordan was of course
remarkable LeBron is incredible a lot of
so many great players and Steph in his
own way is truly remarkable I think to
watch play you just never know what he's
going to do I mean the third quarter and
the way he played in the second half the
game against the Spurs the other day was
just outstanding yeah Rick it's amazing
I mean he makes so many lucky shots that
it's not luck I mean it's somebody shots
where that one handed off the backboard
I couldn't believe the one layup from
about 12 feet away it seemed like was
insane
that said though Rick even though
statistically they'll have it you know
they'll have the record all-time and
they seal the deal and win the
championship they're still not in your
mind the best team ever so then who is
yeah well that's the first objective I
mean yes the district teams during
there's the teams that dominate and play
well during the time that they're
playing are the best teams
that particular there's a lot of great
teams a lot of people think the 76ers in
1967 that we played in the finals who
think is one of the greatest teams ever
and then some of them Showtime Laker
teams and then you've got the Boston
Celtics office you can choose from a
number of teams that they had over the
years so it really doesn't matter and it
is just good talk you know what people
want to get together and discuss it have
an argument there's a about it hopefully
do it the feasible manner but there's
been a lot of great teams in the league
and right now the Warriors are the best
team in the NBA and I just look at it as
a team enjoyable to watch and I think
the Warriors are helping because they're
doing like what the Spurs have done is
they've been the preeminent team I think
over the last 10 to 15 years as far as
the way they play the game and now the
Warriors are doing that and that
buttonholes are left the Spurs and when
to the Hawks and the Hawks are starting
to play that way and I think teams and
coaches are finally realizing it you
know let's get back to playing and
people say it's old school but old
school basketball is the way the game
was designed to be played unselfishly
passing it around not all this
one-on-one stuff I mean last year in the
playoffs it was almost embarrassing what
they tried to get LeBron to have to do
to help them try to win there were so
many times that LeBron had the ball
brought it up the floor and there was
never a pass in the entire possession I
mean I mean I'm talking about a lot cuz
I wrote for the examiner during that
time and I charted it and I was blown
away and then maybe only one pass where
as the Warriors surpassed it at four or
five six times and it's just fun to
watch and play that way and that's the
way the game I think is more fun for the
fans it's more fun for the players it's
just better toe trick totally agree
we're sharing a brain on this one it's
Rick Barry he is a basketball Hall of
Famers in a cool website hydrous
performance calm that's not that's not
that's not my website that's the website
that people should check out because
people walk around and they're
dehydrated they don't even know it and
it causes a lot of health issues just go
to hydrous hydr u.s. performance comm
check it out read about it put 24 in the
promo code if you decide to order some
product there's no sugar in it and it's
got all kinds of medical things to show
you that this is the best hydration
product out there and it's going to get
the hype the electrolytes as if water
your system much faster than anything
else we'll try it and I think you'll
feel a lot better when you go to Rick
Perry 24 comm and read about my fishing
trips and stuff if you want I like it
you're right Rick there are a lot of
people that aren't quite as hydrated as
they should be I wanted to ask you are
people yeah 60 to 70 percent I know I'm
not I tell my wife I tell my sister to
everybody they need to drink more water
than they do and obviously they can
check out that website I wanted to ask
you about the playoffs in particular and
when we have these debates and these
discussions of the best teams and the
greatest teams how much stock you put in
in terms of the ease in which they go
through the playoffs oh I'm a Philly guy
Rick and when I was really young that's
when Moses Malone had the fo fo-fo I
know they lost one game but to go 12 and
one to sweep the Knicks and sweep the
Lakers was really impressive for this
discussion how important you think it is
when we talk about this Golden State
team for years and years to come how
important I think it is that they really
show their dominance throughout the
postseason well I don't necessarily do
you have to be dominant you just want to
win I mean the whole goal for the season
is to get there and win the championship
and it doesn't matter how you want it if
you you know if you have to go seven
games in every series what the heck
difference does it make as long as you
find a way to win doesn't matter if you
can do it easier I mean talk about stuff
I mean come on our seventy-five King is
the greatest upset in the Finals history
for the NBA there's there I mean we
swept the team that was supposed to
sweep us we were named is supposed to be
a playoff team that year so that was a
remarkable accomplishment so all of
those things the team with Moses
obviously that was a great thing twelve
and one of the playoffs and that's just
some fantastic performance on their part
you rarely will ever see something like
that happen to playoff competition and
so it but as a player your objective is
to win if it takes six games five games
in each series to me what difference
does it make
as long as you win and you move on and
get to that finals and find a way to win
there you know as a fan I'd love to see
seven games you know why because I love
greatness I'd love to
watch great people in all walks of life
and in sports it's so great when
everything is on the line when it's the
last game
it's either champion or not a champion
because I love how players perform under
those circumstances
that's when pressure can become a fact
you see I'm a big believer pressure does
not exempt I hate that's used so often
it's ridiculous because if you have
confidence in your ability to do what it
is you've trained to do you live for
those situations those situations are
everything's on the line it's not
pressure it's only pressure if you lack
confidence in your ability to perform
under those critical situations and
that's what I'd love to see how does a
guy perform or a lady perform when it's
all on the line
talking with Rick Barry he's a NBA Hall
of Famer had a just a terrific career
he's the all-time leader in free-throw
percentage Rick is there a guy you're
older than me is there a guy that we can
compare Steph to is there anybody he
reminds you how is that I don't think
I've ever seen in my lifetime no no
absolutely not here's the thing and but
let me correct you I'm not the all-time
leader I would have been if I have a
shooting free throws that way I shot my
last six years one to my last six years
I said over 92% my last two years I
showed over 94% but you know so but
that's just a little tidbit you know as
far as sniff goes I I classify guys who
play their position in any sport and in
way that's different than anybody else
has done it they're an anomaly okay
Magic Johnson was an anomaly will
chamber them was an anomaly LeBrons an
anomaly Steph Curry is an anomaly
there's never been a guy playing the
point guard position who has played the
game the way that Steph plays the game
no one last question Rick kobe bryant's
playing his last game ever tonight
20 years with the Los Angeles Lakers
what will you remember about Kobe what's
the most impressive thing about him and
his career to you Rick I've always been
a Kobe fan happy that he's had this nice
going-away party in all the places that
he's gone what sticks out for me and
what I
hire the most is the fact that Kobe
Bryant was one of those players who
every time he put his uniform on he gave
you everything that he had and I can't
say more than that about an athlete that
he gave everything he had
every time he suited up where she suited
up that to me is the ultimate compliment
for an athlete
well said there's no question about I
bet you he gives everything he has
tonight for sure in his last one Rick
thanks for hopping aboard I appreciate
it my pleasure tell Dad I said I I will
do that there is Rick Perry the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience